what is going on in this industry
there's so many people right now and
you've talked about a lot of them that
are just fraudulent they're there and
all other words they're just disgusting
you're gonna basically put your job but
look at all these people or should be
successful with my program does not
basically represents that as the normal
case you don't wanna do something better
you wanna do something different you
know you've got people that go in there
that bull will spend $40,000 we're
getting a $4,000 of debt and they'll end
up becoming a manager at Starbucks and
right now listen to me listen look me in
the eyes
you can come on posses up and give your
case please I welcome you to my show
don't ban your students for commenting
come on the show baby we're gonna make
yours today we have spencer van guys
this is a call i've been excited about
for a while
spencer is sort of a guru right like
would you call yourself a guru i get it
i mean i do i do the marketing for as
someone that teaches so i guess i'm a
guru so you run a course right or you
help run a course i help run of course
that's correct and you reached out to me
because you wanted to talk about sort of
maybe defend the gurus a little bit show
the other side of the thing because my
channel obviously talks about a certain
side of it you want to talk about the
other side so let's get into it
yeah and you know before we do that um I
will say when I when you say defend it's
it's less defend I'm just tired of this
because I go around now people ask me
what I do and I tell them all you know I
work and we sell this program and like
80% of people jump tell this guy this
guy's a scam because of what is going on
in this industry there's so many people
right now and you've talked about a lot
of them that are just fraudulent they're
there and all other words they're just
disgusting and being in an industry with
those people you know it associates you
with them even though that's not what
you're doing and so I'm just kind of
frustrated of that and that's why I
wanted to come up here and and just give
you a different perspective I'm not
trying to change anyone's mind I don't
think that's what's gonna happen today
for sure for sure no I think that's
totally fair I want you to present the
other side of the coin and I'm glad you
admit and I appreciate you just right up
front saying yeah there's a lot of
scammy stuff going on in this industry
why do you think that is why do you
think this industry
cific alee it doesn't seem to be the
outlier that is scammy it seems to be
like the normal and it may be the more
legitimate cases if it feels like
they're less they're less noticed
well I there's a couple reasons first of
all is you know there's different types
of gurus and I don't know how in depth I
can go with this just talking about it
but there's the type of guru that is
running an actual business selling
programs and an example of that would be
Sam Evans right and then there's a type
of guru that is promoting strictly
promoting a lifestyle and so you you
look at those people and you say okay
who are those people well those people
as I'm sure a lot of your followers have
Instagram right you go on Instagram and
you're getting the Shopify ads you say
hey there's some guy that is uh sitting
on a Lamborghini telling you to swipe up
and follow him and shoot them a deal
okay that's a guy that's promoted but
that's a big thing that's going on right
now right in terms of thousands of
dollars every single day are being sold
through that and it's like well why is
that okay it's because number one is
courses there's no product cost so once
you make it it's you know you're selling
something for thousand dollars that I'm
not paying for it's just pure profit
except for the ad cost of course but
problem okay right and then number two
is you know a lot of these people get
into it especially the younger guys they
get into it because oh this is the
lifestyle you know an entrepreneur
someone that drives around in a
Lamborghini and when I sell of course if
I have a land we gain it helps me sell
it so it justifies it to them and and
it's just this perpetual cycle that
continues on and on wrong so I think
that just the money that's in it number
one and then the fact that it's so low
barrier to entry yeah so II I mean you
could right now if you you're like you
know what these fakers I need to do
something better you could go start a
course and have it you know you start
selling tomorrow it's that easy
all right now how successful you're
gonna be depends on your skill level but
at the end of the day actually getting
into the business it's not that
difficult you know it's there's liver
and low bird edge so right right you
just launched a webinar you get the
click like Clickbank you know account
all that kind of stuff you get hit the
ground run and run some athletes yeah if
that like I you know we talked about the
DM thing but I mean for God's sakes you
know you talked about a jet set flying
like what did he do he just went to an
event and spoke for an hour and made you
know a couple events and scanned by half
a million dollars
so it's like even you know forget the
webinar the webinar is hard forget that
just put a you know buy some fake fall
arrestor gram and send some DMS and you
made a couple thousand bucks I mean it
really is that easy unfortunately but
you know it is so now yeah right no I
know absolutely so why you came on to
basically say but there's this other
side you guys are talking about the the
Guru's you mentioned Sam ovens is being
legit obviously I've talked about Sam
ovens look a little bit a little bit
about his testimonial so I've got a
certain opinion but I want to hear I
want to hear your point of view well you
do matter and your videos were hilarious
by the way but I think with and we
talked about this on the phone but with
with you know with with gurus you have
to you can't it's not all or nothing
okay so you know there's people and I
brought him up a lot this call ready but
Jets that felt like that's out of a 10
he's a 10 out of 10 in terms of his
fraudulent Ness right he is as
fraudulent as scam if you can get and
then there's you know everything before
that there's a one two three four and
all the way up to you know to nine and
10 and so the question is where does
everyone fall you know one would be
someone like an Andrew argue who no one
probably no one knows that follows you
Andrew argues a guru he makes about a
million a month or so selling a course
strictly to accountants helping them
grow their existing business same same
concept but he's only selling it to
accountants he's not trying to sell and
I know the one thing that you you don't
like it's people sign do you know the
Lord Democrat probably can't afford
these things right right but you know
that's someone that clearly doesn't do
that that's only work when it counts
then you get to you know everybody else
you know that's not strictly business
people or strictly working with business
people one of those people Sam right he
works with all types of people and the
question is okay you know does he say
something as a marketing that are
probably not perfect no of course not
nobody does there's no company ever
that's been perfect in our marketing up
okay number one but number two is really
what's the quality of this product
you know how good is his product and the
fact that you know you posted a video
and I don't know how many people
contacted you but you've had a couple
people at least contact you and say you
know what I've actually been in Sam's
course and even though you're bashing
him I would like to come on and defend
him and I know you said he even had
someone that was like no I can't make it
is this true because like you know Sam
told me not to or something like that I
don't want to take words out your mother
no yeah there was a guy who we were
gonna have an another testimonial about
Sam ovens he was like hey I'm up in
California I like I'm like ex-google I
wanted to talk about Sam ovens because I
think he's I think he's legit
and we set up the call and then later he
was like oh no I don't want to do the
call because Sam says you shouldn't
focus on the haters or something I'm on
the show don't come on the show I mean
ultimately that's that's up to you sure
yeah no there were people who wanted to
talk about Dan lock I mean there have
been a lot of a lot of people who have
reached out to me and I want to make
clear I don't know I don't know Dan I
don't know anything about I'm very
little I know about Dan okay I've really
seen his YouTube videos so I'm not gonna
stay here and try to talk about Dan
because I don't know but Sam I know a
lot more and an obviously backer I look
very close relationship with them and
and those guys from what I've seen okay
everything that I've worked with them on
has been legitimate their products have
done me personally results I've seen
them get results of other people you
know are they perfect no okay but on the
scale of things they're nowhere near a
tender nowhere near a five I would put
Sam it like a two and a half or three I
would put Beckert a three and a half for
strictly because his ads are a little
bit crazy as I know he's seen oh yeah
sure sure
to me to me a lot of the Becker and Sam
Evans question all comes down to
demographics right like I don't have any
problem with somebody like the guy who I
did have on the program who was a fan of
Sam Evans I I have no problem with
someone like him you know getting a Sam
Evans course he has like a master's
degree in marketing he has a marketable
skill and he's created a consulting
business out of it sure sure but the
other guy who came on who didn't get
results he's talking about how Sam Evans
just basically takes anybody and
regurgitates course information from a
bunch of books so that's the part where
I'm like how is this course justified
charging two thousand dollars all based
on the marketing idea that I'm going to
get you from basically from step one
zero two steps
hero I mean that
that's mostly what I have a problem with
I agree though with your core contention
which is that hey this guy isn't as bad
as someone like jet set fly who's
literally you know being fraudulent you
know right taking literally any scraping
people's last dime together and getting
him in the course I would really like to
see look to me to me
I think these gurus have taken it for
granted that they should just be assumed
to be legit and fair whatever and I
don't think you can make that any guru
industries so bad that I think guru
should start proactively basically
saying like look these are the
demographics I'm targeting let me just
be transparent with you guys I'm not
targeting people who are making less
than X dollars a year because I don't
think they should be a good fit for my
would be a good fit my question I think
they should start if they have such a
thing you can't blame people for being
skeptical of an industry that is so rife
with predatory behavior I think
skepticism should be the norm and you
should wait until basically especially
when it's a two thousand dollar course
with like a twenty five hundred dollar
upsell and then another upsell after
that for actual one-on-one consulting
right no and and first of all I think we
just says right you should never like if
you're gonna buy a course someone's on
Becker says if someone's online yelling
at you on how to make money you should
be skeptical and he says it as ads for a
psychological reason but it's true like
you shouldn't be on you shouldn't be
like you know what I'm not really sure
about this guy but let me just send over
two thousand we'll figure it out like
you should know this guy is legit okay
the problem is now and this is a
multi-faceted problem because what you
just said is they ever should have
skepticism that's true the other hand is
is now there's so many fake gurus that
now the people that can actually help
people get pushed out it that's that's
the problem
you know because there's so many you
know like you talked about and this is
something you brought up and I want to
bring this up today with jets that fly I
talked about okay well why don't you
talk more about guys like that instead
of guys like salmon II said well yeah
you know jets that fly as you mentioned
is clearly a lot more fragile
but Sam has touched a lot more people
right okay for everyone who's listening
me and Spencer how to call previous to
this we're kind of referencing some of
those things said in that call so just
FYI let's try to build from like the
ground up just so everyone's like fully
conscious yeah I'll give the argument
for a second because Spencer would
basically like hey there's so many
people that are much worse than sama and
I'll agree with that and actually I I
kind of I kind of said in the in the tin
red-flags video which was like look
there's a sliding scale of of terrible
right generally I don't think you should
be buying courses people on the internet
but that's my personal opinion okay but
Spencer's point was look why don't you
focus on the guys who are like the
bigger scams and actually we've got a
guy coming I think this Friday who's
pretty bad I'm hopping on a call right
of this to do that to do exactly that
but what I told him was hey look there's
two things that I consider when thinking
about a faker
one is how how fraudulent are they or
how much of a fake guru are they even if
it's not front how much of like of the
false advertisin water and then I said
you also have to consider how many
people is this guy bringing in because I
think that affects how valuable the
consumer information is if a guy's super
scammy but he only affects one person a
year I don't really want to waste my
time so I thought Sam Evans was
interesting because he's really at the
top of the guru game it seems like he's
like one of the biggest he's him Becker
Dan Locke I mean those are like the
three big names I know there's some
others I'm forgetting about right now
Kevin David that's someone else I want
to do guys everyone's been asking for
Kevin Davis I will do get to Kevin David
but uh but that's what the conversation
was about so go ahead pick up where I
love ya know and I again I wore was I I
I'm with you there and I apologize about
that some referencing things people
don't remember but yeah I guess my point
is in bringing that up is you know
you're absolutely right there's
obviously first of all when we say Sam
this is the guy as I and sure I keep
referenced just but he's the guy by a
large margin I'm not gonna share his
exact numbers because I don't know his
exact member from what I was told
from someone that is basically his
right-hand man
the numbers that they gave me would put
him well above everyone else that I know
of which is I want to say everybody but
I know most of the big player okay at
least from a distance you know but
anyways I'm sure so with that being said
I kind of get where you're coming from
but at the same time here's the thing
that's interesting about education
versus other products right so right
here I have my iPhone okay and if I were
to sell you this iPhone and it didn't
work
you would just refund you just hey you
know send it back like send me any ones
it doesn't work okay
or you would just turn on and would
start working like those are the two
options okay sure with education it's a
very unique industry where the customer
has to be countered into that because my
information can be the best in the world
and let's say hypothetically like I I go
around I pay tens of millions of dollars
to get the best expert experts in the
world and create a course about how to
make a youtube channel okay or something
like that right right and I sell to you
for five thousand dollars and you never
watch it well who's whose fault is that
that you didn't get success like what
where's the line that it becomes
businesses versus the customers fault
and here's the thing as a business owner
it's always my fault like that's always
my rule because I'm trying to get
everyone success but at some point
logically speaking there is a line where
it says okay this is no longer the
businesses fault the customer literally
did not use the product yeah you know II
mean so so I would say that specifically
is the line we can like point in the
sand that when a customer is not
watching the educational content that is
the line at which point the business
should not be held accountable for
somebody saying it didn't work for me
and that is where I'd like to push that
I think a lot of times the what I've
seen in a lot of my guru comment
sections it doesn't matter who it is
they always say oh this person didn't
try hard enough this person didn't he
just didn't put in the work and that's a
very cool it's a true excuse in some
cases but in other cases it's a great
way to push off blame for a product
you're not actually working and so
you're right it is kind of complicated
but at the same time I always kind of
hesitate because I've I've had for
example specifically with Sam ovens I
had a guy on who is like yeah like I
went through his whole course
me pictures of like his could progress
completion bar it was like 98% are some
it was some something like that and it
was like yeah I didn't get any results
that to me is you can't say oh the guy
didn't try hard enough because I know in
Sam diamonds case there's like many many
hours of content he went through all of
it and he's like I put in the work I did
do the stuff and I'm not getting results
in that case where do you I'm interested
in what you think because 100 percent
how do you feel about that so let me let
me just break this down and this is you
want to get some insider scoop on what
gurus talking about this is what girls
talking about okay so in any info
business there is you have a few
different type of customers okay you
have the cat and it's okay if I share my
screen you kind of draw this out because
I think this would make more sense if I
did yeah sure let's see here alright can
you uh let's see can you see this
whiteboard here
if I draw this well oh yeah yeah totally
okay so on any let me make this red to
says even easier to see okay on any you
know as far as gurus go you have this
contingency of customers okay the first
thing you have is the top ten maybe
fifteen percent of people that join your
program these are a people that like you
you know you interviewed that guy you
said you'd a master's degree like he's
probably already successful and they're
just real go-getters in life and the
question becomes that seems like as a
guru you can't win because like your
point is like oh well he would have been
successful anyway because he was already
you know he's he was already on the path
he said he would miss enough lately
which in some case is probably true
right um on other cases is who knows how
long that would have taken it maybe
would have taken him a lot longer like I
don't know I think he's specifically
credited to be fair to him and his
testimony I think he specifically
credited Sam Evans week jump-starting
his career serenity in his own words he
said look he got me there much faster
than I could have by myself but fair
enough okay so anyway that's ten to
fifty I'm gonna put 10% us time fifteen
percent of people that come in they're
already like on the path to be
successful it's just a matter of giving
them a little bit more focus yeah that's
really a lot okay then you've got
another thirty to forty percent I know
these are not gonna be proportional but
there's a matter
okay that are you know these are people
that you know they're they're very
interested maybe they're they're
beginners there they are driven okay but
they need a little bit more help than
the than the 10% that is already there
okay
an example of this person for my
business we teach people how to start
real estate businesses so it would be
someone that you know doesn't already
have a successful business in any
industry or maybe they do but it's very
low level of success maybe they've done
one real estate deal and they're like I
don't know how to do another one you
know something like that okay you know
again new but driven you're committed to
it okay then you've got another 30% of
people okay that will watch the program
they'll watch all of it and they'll try
it okay now the level of trying it
varies okay so maybe they'll try it and
you know for us you know we teach a how
to go out and contact people that are
looking or that would just foreclosed on
and try to help them okay how you know
how many of these calls are they
actually making right there's all these
questions okay for Sam I've never been
through consulting accelerator which is
of course actually know the guy I was
talking about up level okay up level
he's basically helping people start you
know create what's called a video sales
letter or VSL or a webinar and then for
these for him it would be like okay what
30% of people probably go through the
course and maybe they try doing a
webinar like they build some slides out
or something like that's that's that 30%
okay and these are the people that it's
your job if your course is really good
you have to get it many as many of these
people over to this side as possible
meaning that you have to get them to
commit you have to get them to take
action because they leave the day as you
briefly touched on you can watch 98% of
the course if you don't actually do it
it doesn't matter that's the thing about
education like you can you can use the
whole product that's why I brought up
the line because you know where the line
is where you said I could what line
should be will they watch through the
whole course well it can't be that
because just cuz you watch the whole
course doesn't mean you don't watch the
videos and they make money if this all
works right you got your fun and your
take action okay so that's right and
then you have five to ten 10% of people
and I don't know if these numbers make
any sense but you have the last five ten
percent of people that they they're
quite honestly they are they're crazy
they truly believe that
you know they're literally if they watch
a video that they're going to make money
I'll get me a double this we had a
customer and I'm not gonna share any
personal information obviously we had a
customer this is that the last section
because that would have been 30% of the
customers is that sort of what you might
remember said if the rest of percentage
will go in split evenly between the two
again I'm not doing them back sure sure
sure sure no worries no worries I
appreciate the clarification okay yeah
so um anyways to give you a brief
example here we had a customer who
bought our program in October of 2018
okay it is now October 2000 of 90 knows
we are recording this okay he went
through the program and you know hopped
um
we do five coaching calls a week hopped
on our coaching calls for months for
months okay and then in about April of
this year it just disappeared we just
stopped hearing from that that was it
I'm stopped hearing from and we have a
lockout so we you know sound like we're
like chase me blonde so we don't get you
know since your choice to be here not so
a couple literally like probably last
week again I get an email and you always
know it's it's not a good email when
someone sends you an email with all caps
as the subject line oh my god this was
not gonna be good right
oh and I I go I read through those email
and the email he's like Spencer I've
gone through this course you know I've
been on some some coaching calls which
was true he had been on some coaching
calls you know I haven't I haven't had
success okay I would like to get a
refund but okay sure you know we have
and I know you want to talk about
action-based refunds which well more
haven't talked to you about yeah sure
through we have three requirements for
our action base number one is that you
complete the course number because I
mean if you're gonna buy a course
hopefully you would complete it that
would make sense right number two is
that you actually go on and you know you
attend to coaching calls he had clearly
done that so that wasn't gonna question
and the number three is that UK you got
and you make some some calls you know
with potential deals now our requirement
is 200 in 30 days which becomes out to
less than 10 a day and we always say do
10 a day five days a week for four weeks
whatever okay that's what we teach
anyways so it was not a question whether
doing the coaching calls the only
question was had he completed the course
and had he made the calls fair enough
okay and even though our refund
guarantee is thirty days he was very
upset I said dude just show us you've
done these two things and we'll give you
a refund I have no problem with that
what's up okay so I go through and on
our back-end we can see how much of the
she's gone through I can go through he's
gone through literally eight percent of
the course in a year eight percent okay
so probably not a hundred that not even
close right so I said okay sure not even
close
okay fair enough so uh you know hey you
know he's upset I can tell hey you know
what look man if you've made the calls
will still give you a refund even though
you haven't done it I mean really you
haven't used a product we have a 30 day
refund guarantee it's been a year okay I
don't know what write all these things
against you but you don't we'll talk
could you send us some information that
they you've made some calls and and you
know we'll go out and give you a real
hey you know what Spencer I'm really
busy you know but just just give me a
refund and we just go back and forth I
shouldn't say we my support team goes
back and forth of them for like five or
six emails and it's like every time
we're like I did just send in some
information you made some calls he
changes the subject and says oh well you
know just give me well dude you're
you're into it right so what that tells
me is he clearly has not done it if
you've watched eight percent of the
course
and you know he's made he's made some
calls then why why wouldn't he be able
to send those that yeah I don't think I
don't think we disagree on this I mean
this is it like if your point is is that
oh this this kind of customer will
complain but should not really be
allowed to I mean people shouldn't take
their complaints seriously like I don't
think they're I don't think those are
credible complaints in my mind this is
my point though my point is I'm trying
to figure out with you because we're
competitors that's right we're complete
opposites on the spectrum to be on this
call because of that okay yeah sure
because I want to know in your
perspective okay hearing that a true
story where does the line fall because
originally it was hey you know what if
they go through the course and I don't
get results okay well there's more than
that right if they go through the course
and don't take the action then maybe
that's where the line should be of when
complaints are if they go through they
go through the course and they have at
like when does it become the customers
fault versus the businesses fault that
they that they don't get results and
honest as a genuine question for you i
don't know i don't know the answer that
so I'm asking you yeah yeah I think
that's a I think that's a really good
question well I think it depends on what
kind of marketing you're doing what kind
of guarantees you're trying to imply
because I know every guru on there under
the Sun will have some fine print about
you know get results are not guaranteed
but there are certain implications
everybody's marketing is making okay
like the most egregious example is
obviously people like Kevin David
obviously were to do a video on him but
he's like he's always talking about like
you're gonna basically quit job look at
all these people or should be successful
with my program didn't uh he basically
represents that as the normal case so
where his the even in his case if
somebody doesn't watch his videos I
wouldn't hold that against him what I do
hold against him is when people do try
to do the Shopify or Amazon I think it
as Amazon FBA Amazon FBA and they it's
really not as easy as all David thought
said it was and they actually give it a
real chance and like some good chunk
let's say 30 40 percent of his
customers are watching the videos trying
the product and not getting the results
and I think the person I'm giving him
the benefit of the doubt there are not
getting the results he's promising and
paying thousands of dollars in order to
enjoy that failure and waste their time
that's that to me as a fake guru so a
lot of a lot of where I kind of kind of
harassed gurus what I harass them about
is is their claims because I just think
like I'm very skeptical of any proven
system you know that if you follow these
groups everyone's always talking about
proven steps like you just need a proven
system you need two proven steps proven
that's proven that and it's like why
make those claims I think a much more
honest sales pitch is look I have X
experience in this industry
I am personally successful for a variety
of luck and hard work and I want to
share my perspective with you and I'm
gonna teach you everything I know
join my course I think you'll get a lot
about you out of it now I think the come
back to that is well that wouldn't be a
successful sales pitch I mean the
comeback is how can I compete with all
the guys selling Lamborghinis how can I
compete with everyone who's making the
guarantees of you're gonna make a
full-time income you're gonna do all
these things and that is the that's the
part of it where I kind of feel I can't
believe I'm saying this I feel a little
bit bad for goose because it is true
that if you are completely honest about
you really I can't make any promises to
you guys really this is a really hard
business really in all honesty getting a
regular job is probably a better option
for 90% of people very true if they
would say that dude I have no problem
with any guru like it is all in the
advertising where that line is between
what is false representation false
advertising and you know whatever and
yeah I totally agree sometimes it is the
customers bad but a lot of times more
often the gurus want to admit people do
try they do try the product they do do
all that and they aren't succeeding and
where is the testimonials for those
people where is the where's the
presentation for those people it's not
existing you won't find out on anybody's
website and won't find it in anyone's
sales like you'll find it on my my
channel alright that's it it's like
that's it that's all I do you're totally
right I mean I think I think that's
that's what we should attack is the
advertising and you know again I kind of
briefly touched on on how there's two
you know archetypes that I've seen of
gurus and basically you know the two
that I've summarized and and I just to
give your audience a brief summary I
started this company two years ago
November of 2017 so basically two years
before that I had been in real estate I
got my real science really I was 18
years old I don't teach when I talk
about because even though I understand
it at a high level most you know more
than most people I'm not an expert okay
I partnered with someone who's done it
for 15 years so just oldest primer aside
but anyways I bring that up because you
know as far as the marketing goes and
this is something again we talked about
on our call but you know when it comes
to selling something like basic sales
principles or this do you buy a drill or
do you buy the hole that the drill
creates and the truth is you buy the
hole that the drill creates right you're
not buying a drill - look at how cool
the drill is you're like oh this is like
most people don't buy you like oh this
is such a cool drill no you're like I
want to hang something on my wall I want
to drill in you know this screw and I
wanna hang it okay so that's with that
principle in mind that is why gurus talk
about results and there's two different
ways that grew to type that gurus try to
sell okay number one and this is where I
am in a hundred percent agreement with
you that these people they're
necessarily scams in terms of the price
or scams but the way they're selling is
very sketchy and scumming okay there's
language is when they sell through
what's called significance so they're
selling through hey I am X years old and
I made X amount of dollars and I'm so
cool and I have a Lamborghini and you
know I rented a private jet okay and
like like that when they're selling that
way that's when for me because I know
this I'm the business that's what my
like alarm bells start going off because
I might like if really what you talk
about works why don't you have people
other than yourself that have done it
you know yeah so that's number one the
second way that gurus try to sell is
with is with success or student success
you know more and more and more
specifically okay and that is you know
hey like Santa you watch Sam's webinar
you talk about this a lot hey you know
what we've had X amount of students come
in here we have X
matter of results we have a fair amount
of things and here's the thing too I
love Sam I really do but the thing about
Sam and Sam's product is amazing
the thing about salmon this goes with
all gurus well dude I'm gonna do the
math for you do the math watch his
webinar and do the math he brings up a
slide that says he's got X amount of
students X amount of them have become
millionaires an S amount of them have
have have quit their job and and
whatever okay and and do math you can
figure out the percentage of success in
his course okay he literally has a slide
that says I have this many people on the
course I have this many people that have
become millionaires and I have this many
people that have quit I mean it's not a
hidden fact so that's number one but
anytime a guru is using significance to
sell whether it's a Lamborghini or you
know I made a million or here's me like
talking about my job I've been watching
videos about John Frusciante do this
hilarious okay like I don't know what's
up with him and the Benjamins I don't
know it's no offense to John Frusciante
I've never met him but he seems like a
great guy I don't know okay a little
questionable okay it's a little
questionable okay but I don't I
genuinely don't know so I don't want a
ragam I don't know but from what I've
seen what the Benjamins it's just a
little okay um but yeah I mean when
that's the way that you're selling
something you know okay that's the
equivalent of being like hey man I've
made a million dollar so buy my iPhone
it's like that doesn't even make sense
they're not even correlate like like
just because you're teaching her how to
make money like it doesn't they're not
correlated you know I mean so so that's
that's red flag number one but I'm sorry
does that doesn't really answer your
question or is more of an open debate no
I mean no I I think I think we like
pretty much agree on that point it's
like I really I do think it all comes
down to the advertising and I do have a
little bit of sympathy okay cuz I know I
can put myself in the perspective of
maybe let's say coffee break had a fake
guru quartz which I'm not ruling out no
guru course okay guys just dream dream
about that tonight a two thousand dollar
coffee Zillah fake guru course and I
would feel a lot of pressure to get
conversions and when you're like a be
testing you know ads and whatever and
you have two ads let's say you have two
ads you have
the ad that makes wild promises and yet
that is very straightforward and sells
the drill sells the actual drill and I
want to talk about why I think the money
might the money-making thing is a
specific industry where you need more
strict advertising but I know that the
one where I make promises would get more
clicks and I know it'd be extremely
tempting to run that ad because as a
calculation as a business you just go oh
well I'm just getting more customers
that is a pretty fundamental calculation
every business guy gets so do I am i
sympathetic to gurus for basically
making a very fundamental calculation
yeah I'm a little sympathetic but I
think
it is the consumer should be made aware
of the falseness of that advertising and
I think it shouldn't shouldn't be
allowed but unless YouTube or Facebook
is gonna actually take action on it it's
hard to know who to completely hold
accountable because they're in a
competitive market I mean ultimately I
do hold the Guru's accountable but I
also understand that in order to get
popular and sell your course if the if
the environment is clickbait I mean it's
sort of like a YouTube channel if the
environment is clickbait there's a
tremendous pressure to click they I get
like I get that I get that sure I don't
but ultimately I don't think it's right
and I this is what I want to get into
specifically money-making courses I find
health wealth and happiness are three
industries where there is the most
predatory marketing and here's why
here's why if I sell you if I sell you
this iPhone let's say since we're going
with the iPhone thing there is no need
for you to buy that thing so ultimately
no matter how I market it you never
really need this thing you never really
need it and so you can make a pretty
honest calculation but let's say I'm
sick right let's say I'm sick and you're
telling me that your herbal supplement
is going to cure my cancer whatever all
of a sudden that's a much different miss
advertising that's going on because I
have to I am like I have to go buy that
thing I need my health the same thing
with money
if yours telling me you're gonna make me
rich and I think that is why I courses
often focus so much around money are
focused on financial freedom and all
that is because it's an inflexible
demand product I mean if you have your
secret to make me wealthy I'll pay any
amount to get it if you have the secret
to make me well I'll pay any amount to
get it but if you have you know some
phone you say is gonna change my life I
can buy it or I cannot buy it it's a
much more it's that the price the price
curve is much more competitive there's
no there there isn't so much of like I
can just charge whatever amount I want
for it and so that's where I think the
scummy nature of this business to me
gets ratcheted up because when you have
gurus saying I'm gonna take you out of
your financial situation you're stuck at
Wendy's screwed up you know you're
trying to make a better life for
yourself and you see this guy on the
internet who's working out who's at the
beach and whatever and you think oh my
gosh I'll do anything to get out of my
situation that's that's where it gets
predatory to me and I think that's why
they actually make so much money so I'm
not just against false advertising I'm
specifically against false advertising
in the Guru industry because of the
product that y'all sell is an inelastic
product that everyone needs mmm
we're all dying for money and so if you
promise me money I want to believe you
it's so much easier for me to get
suckered in and and by the way I
completely agree I I am a
I'm against false advertising everywhere
I'm not against all's every time just
it's better but I will say this by the
way recently I had the opportunity to
watch your video on your main channel
about pyramid schemes and there was a
clip in there oh that was hilarious that
was the the sales guy talking about like
oh yeah like if you you know if you
needed a medical treatment or something
I mean that's ridiculous right just to
serve you that didn't watch the sales
guys this MLM meeting was basically
teach people how to sell and you know so
I was like what if they said they don't
have money and he's like well if you
needed ten thousand or whatever was ten
thousand dollars to buy your mom heart
surgery you know you'd find the money so
they're gonna find the money if they
really want it like that was his that
was his point
taylor j fox he goes he goes if you guys
don't have $500 I mean maybe you're just
not cut out to be wealthy if you don't
have if you can't scrape together $500
for my course maybe you're just not cut
out for it
it's like the the scam is that it's
terrible by the way another future but
but it's I mean it's pretty terrible
like like that and that is how they
ultimately get people you could charge
basic almost any amount for people to
scrape together and and then if they
don't make it get the results I'm not
saying you're saying this but what most
gurus say is they sweep all of them
under the rug under the true but
misleadingly true characterization of
well they just didn't try enough it's
true for some of them but for a lot of
the a lot of the people who lost money
it's not true and so where where is the
the fairness for those people it's like
you're sure I wanna make out the Guru
industry I want to make one point clear
you mention earlier you know you said
hey if you're going online saying you're
gonna make people rich I don't think any
guru that you've I mean I shouldn't say
don't know Sam ovens specifically Alex
Becker I don't think they ever say hey
I'm going to make you rich I don't think
that's a that's a phrase I don't think
they say they closed that my
understanding of what we do and I
learned directly from Becker okay Sam
ovens not as much but obviously you know
Becker is very close to Sam so I hear a
lot of what's going on there and you
know from what I've heard specifically
okay the pitches hey you know what I
cannot guarantee you're gonna die you're
gonna see these results or that you're
gonna get these results but I can
guarantee you're gonna see how many
people did okay that's that's the pitch
right so
it's not a matter of hey I'm guarantee
you're gonna get these rolls I'm not
what I'm saying is I'm gonna guarantee
you're gonna see are you gonna get these
results and if you don't get these
results that's fine I'll give you a
refund okay now my kids I can't speak
I'm Becker I can speak on Sam Evans I
literally have because this is what the
other guy was telling me too he goes
share Mabus doesn't promise to make
anybody rich it's literally in his
webinar I understand that he just
recently updated was Wepner I'm not
talking about the new webinar it's it's
the webinar he's been running for years
he knows he goes I will teach you how to
make I can take anyone make that get you
a wildly profitable business do you need
to be a Harvard MBA know you can be you
know anybody at the end then he caveats
and does something but the implication
after it is as long as you put in the
effort really the only distinction
between a successful Sam Evans student
and a non successful one is effort but
that's not actually true the difference
between a successful Sam Ivan student
and an unsuccessful Sam Evans student is
their background what skills they bring
to the table a certain amount of luck a
certain amount of opportunity that the
niche that they happen to choose is it
one that is already saturated I mean
like if they have a certain skill set if
the market is saturated are they going
to be super successful probably not a
lot of entrepreneurship is opportunity
meets preparation and you make some
money but it's like how can that that is
the type of representation and I've
watched his new webinar it's not a scam
II give them a little credit it's not as
skinny as it used to be but that is the
stuff that I call him out for I do
specifically call out gurus based on
their actual representations he was
actually actually representing two
people that fell into a sales funnel
that he was going to basically make you
wildly profitable so long as you gave
him effort okay that is on that case I'm
not saying mothers I'm not gonna speak
on his behalf
okay and I'm not gonna speak on
something I haven't seen so I'm gonna do
from what I've seen okay Tom with that
aside from what I've seen is that people
are not on here at least most maybe Sam
is I don't know okay but promote for
mostly from what I've seen people are
not here say ham I'm gonna make you rich
just give me two large I don't think
that's the pitch I really don't I think
it's clear in most cases now look again
this is where we talk to me go back to
the scale of hey there's really scamming
guys and then there's guys that are not
so bad
you know I think
for the most part other guys that are
not so bad are not saying that I think I
think they're saying hey I can help you
get there you know these are the results
I've gotten okay when they say it's a
proven system what does that really mean
that's first of all what is that what it
what defines a proven system okay yeah
yeah because I I don't I don't answer
that
I know for me a proven system is so if
you can take X amount of people through
the system and they can get results with
it the problem is how many what what
what equals X is it at this point
because I to be naive to talk about it
because everyone always compares college
to like guru education because the
implication is look not everyone is
successful from their college degree
some people still work at college after
our Starbucks after their college
education and they they're $100,000 in
debt that's this huge untalked earns not
talked about it very often people talk
about college as being such a great
thing okay here's the fundamental
distinction between college and gurus
that I think could be at one point fixed
but I would like to see gurus taking an
active what role in trying to make these
statistics available the difference is
is you can go online and you can find
out the average college students income
versus the average non-college educated
person's income and you can find out
that the on average you make a lot more
money in your lifetime and it makes the
tuition cost worth it it makes it's
worth your tuition costs for the average
student when we talk about proven
systems that's what a proven system is
to me not for the extraordinary student
but for the average student what does it
mean for the average student because we
cannot count you cannot account on
yourself being a extraordinary you can
count on yourself being average by
definition so hmm for the average guru
who goes through a program
do they make more than two thousand
dollars over the non guru student in I
don't know even even a lifetime I would
be satisfied with but hopefully like
within a year or two years do they make
up the cost of the course if any guru
could say that and say that with
statistics I would never have a problem
with them because I'd be thinking yeah
yeah sure go through their system
yeah and
is proven you can't just flash but my
problem but what actually happens and
this is what actually is going on is
they show their best students and they
say these guys these extraordinary
students succeeded and they represent
that as the case the the standard case
so what I'd like to see its before you
say I have a proven system go talk to
your actual students the average
students find out how are they doing how
much money are they making are they
making more money than they used to make
if so that's the thing you want to talk
about not hey Joe Blow made 1 billion
dollars you know with my course or
whatever and that's all I'm gonna talk
about for the rest of eternity it's like
it's like yeah you don't know how much
you affected that person that's why the
average case is so perfect is because
you get rid of the noise of someone's
effort and all that you get the average
student you find out what actually is my
course doing I think it's an honest way
to do business but I think it's also an
honest way to evaluate how effective
your course is period I think gurus
should want to know how effective their
courses I agree I think I think though I
think you should clarify are you saying
average or median because you take
average that's kind of a skewed number
can spend their immediate really know
that meeting yeah yeah definitely
good great point yeah I'm with you there
a hundred percent you know my I'm a
college dropping I dropped out of a
Community College I went for a year and
a half I can tell you you may be a
little more into college I am given the
Texas and I'm sure that you're currently
working but no I I think you're
absolutely right you know my in the big
battle we have with college is this in
my opinion this is this is guru Sai this
is my opinion on college sure um you
know I think here's the problem with
college is there is just like you talked
about with gurus there's no
accountability so let's say I go through
college and I get a degree and it
doesn't work for me
can I go get a refund no right I can't
okay I don't know you tell me I did I
didn't go to college for very long so
maybe you can't get a refund I don't
know I'm not college educated oh no no
no you absolutely can't okay that's
number one number two is here's the
other thing when you talk about average
and and and all of that okay so you're
right College the reason why college is
so successful the
really if you think about it what is
what is the point of college
what if colleges have become educated so
that you can get a better paying job you
can make more money that's the point of
gold what's the point of taking a course
that teach you how to make money so you
can be educated so you can make more
money I mean they're very similar in
that aspect now where the differences
lie is that and you tell me if I'm wrong
here this is gonna sound very cliche but
the society as a whole
says you need to be educated okay at
least at least Western society does the
United States of America specifically
says hey you know what we want our
people to be educated which I agree with
100% I think we do need to have more
education and I think right now you know
the cost of college has just become
ridiculous I mean it's just absurd at
this point I'm pretty sure your degrees
in there okay - is this though is with
colleges specifically okay you know
you've got people that go in there that
will spend forty thousand dollars will
get in a four thousand dollars of debt
and they'll end up becoming a manager at
Starbucks so where's the accountability
for that right and you're talking about
okay so the median person is successful
well how successful does it justify
because it cost you forty thousand
dollars to go to college hypothetically
could cost you more cost you less let's
say on average cost you forty thousand
for four years and you end up making two
thousand dollars more a year yeah you'd
make that up on the back end but after
interest all that it's really not gonna
be that big of a difference you know
interest on your student it's not I
don't have the numbers on hand but do I
either I can send you some stuff later
on it's it's a pretty substantial it's
not like you barely squeaked by I mean
it's it's it's I think somewhere in the
range of 20 thousand dollars a year more
but it's pretty it's pretty heavy so
that's that's that side of it the other
thing is is that I think I would so this
was happening for a while with private
for-profit colleges they were heavily
marketing to students they were courting
students saying like oh come here come
here we're gonna make you so much money
than that people freaked out they're
like you can't do this and they were
right by the way to say that you can't
aggressively promise you know you know
future incomes and all that kind of
stuff and that's what a lot of state
schools do not do they don't go around
heavily courting kids kids come because
they have a reputation of success and
they make that decision but
school's not going oh yeah if you go
here I mean like look look here's here's
what you know John did from la blah blah
he's our best case scenario he'll give
you the actual statistics of you know
our average graduate and this degree
will make this much money a year and
it's not the it's not a
misrepresentation and all your costs are
laid out up front I think so on that and
there's also a more honest advertising
going up in some cases obviously
for-profit colleges I have a huge
problem with their huge problem but as
far as public colleges I don't think
they suffer that problem nearly not the
other thing that is different between
gurus and colleges is accreditation so
there is a value not merely in the
education but in the actual diploma
degree is recognized as like a sort of a
status symbol you can't go through Dan
Locke's course and say hey I'm a
high-ticket closer and people don't go
oh wow well we'll move you to the top of
the stack now that you're a high-ticket
closer baby like like that's just not
something that happens and in some jobs
you specifically have to be accredited
to do said job I'd like to be a certain
Allah near you need a PE you need an
engineering degree from a certified
school to be a doctor to be a lawyer I
mean like these are there's a lot of
programs within these rules that
literally you cannot do it without that
thing whereas I think gurus target a lot
of the soft skills where there is no
accreditation needed at all and so what
they're offering is more intangible
which is even more of the reason that
I'd like to see numbers show me numbers
I mean I talk to everybody
anybody that I see that from this
industry I say please send me as many
numbers as you can I want the backend
the lack of transparency is what makes
me unable to verify to trust that's the
thing that's the whole thing right and I
and I agree with you there I think
transparency is very important you know
I think you brought up Dan Locke's
height to get closer I think that's
pretty funny
but you know I will say this as a
business owner did you know Dan Locke's
watching this video right now I you know
I saw your new video about that that's
right
dad how you doing man give me a call
there and let's talk
I apologize dad now I'm just getting bad
that's actually funny but uh not I I
think one thing I'll in defensive Dan
okay then I'll say you know yes you're
right there's no you know if some guy
came to me actually it's funny I did
have someone there I should tell that
story I didn't tell the story but let's
talk about okay so about a year ago
November of 28th October November 2018
our you know we have been running the
webinar we were starting slowly certain
of scaling up I think at that point
we're doing about 25 to 30 new students
a month so super low scale still but you
know making making progress and I had
gotten messaged by who someone who
claimed to be one of dan lock students
now I'm gonna lie I don't know if
there's a database of Dan's students
online where you can search and see if
they're actually a Heitzig like I don't
think that exists okay so I just took
him at his word maybe he wasn't maybe he
was but he convinced me he's like yeah I
work with Dan lock he's my wasn't where
they calm like a seafood seafood that's
what it is my apologies right there
but um anyway he said you know I want to
help you close more sales with a higher
price point I said okay I said can you
really do this we talked for a couple
weeks I said you know what it's worth a
shot let's just try it okay let's change
things up let's change it up a little
bit add some new things to the product
and let's let's try it you know why not
so we did that and we tried it for it
for two weeks and again we were
averaging about one you know maybe 0.75
but 1.5 sales a day before that at a
lower price point but then we
drastically dropped I think we're the
first week we did like two sales like it
was horrible okay and we soon as you
hire the high ticket closers to lose
ground I take a closer so I want to make
this clear I don't I'm not saying Dan
stuff works or doesn't work I don't even
know if this guy was actually related to
them but he claimed to be through the
lines don't sue me dead don't Silvie
seafood yeah then I do not want a
lawsuit I'll just come out and say it
understand you're a great guy I love I
love your suits okay they're great but I
don't know I'm just saying anyway but
yeah so that was my experiment but I
will say in defense of Dan though I will
say this as a business
you know if someone can come to me and
they can genuinely help me with sales ok
and now look they show when they went
through dance course I don't really care
but if they show me hey this is my track
record and I learned this from dance
course but the cells I'm gonna look at
that more Harley I will say us look this
up it and I am going to say this and I
don't I'm a little worried about signs
cuz I don't know the facts directly on
me but I believe I read an article a
while back that said that some of the
biggest companies now on the planet and
are longer requiring a college degree
again not I'm not I'm not going out I'm
not saying which ones I believe it was
Apple I believe it was is either Dell or
Microsoft and there was one other one
like a gun I don't want to say please
look very maybe I may be completely
wrong okay but I'm going I'm just saying
I believe Iran so that's number two and
then the last thing I'll say you know is
at the end of the day you might get it's
like being a good-looking guy or girl
right like if you're a good-looking guy
you want to talk to a girl you're gonna
get in the door just based on how you
look okay most of the time and then
whether or not you know she likes you
she wants to continue talking to you is
gonna be based on what on the level of
confidence that you have talking her on
can you hold a conversation social
skills right sure okay so it's the same
thing with business I might be more apt
to hire someone that has a master's
degree but do they have the skills that
are really gonna help my business
because I'm gonna be honest with you we
track every metric possible with all of
our employees and at the end of the day
if what they're doing is not you know
making like numerical results in our
business we're gonna get rid of them
because we're a business we need to make
money we have bills to pay we have
people we have employees to pay and if
you're not it doesn't matter what degree
you I give you a doctor I don't care you
know if you're not getting results you
don't have the skills to get results
then it doesn't matter and so I'm with
you there I think calls yes it gives you
a little bit more of a foot in the door
in some instances however I will also
say you know does it really get you the
skills that you need to be successful
that's the question and I'm not saying
courses do by the way I'm not saying
gurus do in all cases sometimes I do
sometimes I don't but since we're
talking about college I think that's a
fair point to make one of them I would
say I would say this I don't think it
necessarily for sure it doesn't
guarantee mm anything it doesn't
guarantee that you're gonna be
successful it doesn't guarantee that
that
person's gonna be qualified or a good
worker or it's any of those like
fundamental things but I think it does
teach you the valuable skill of how to
learn how to commit yourself to
something how to work something
long-term that is abstract I mean
sitting through like calculus class will
not make you a better salesman or
something like that but it teaches you
abstract principles it makes you
consider abstract ideas that you had
never thought before fit it into a
larger framework and so later on down
the road when you're let's say you're
doing technical sales and you're selling
to some plant and there's a bunch of
abstract concepts is it gonna is the guy
gonna be asking you to do an integration
no but he might be asking you about some
other high like technical idea that
because you went through college because
you've trained your mind to work with
these ideas you're much more able to
handle that kind of situation that is
generally what I took away from my I did
Chemical Engineering have I ever used
chemical engineering in my life I mean
like practically for money you know
whatever besides like a couple
internships I did no not at all okay do
I regret any second of college no
because it has hugely impacted the way I
do research in my job it's hugely
impacted my my critical thinking you
know all these things so I think there's
a bunch of intangibles related to
college education that are that are hard
to quantify that do come out later in
the in how successful the people will be
on the individual case though
anecdotally I'm sure a bunch of masters
degrees kids are idiots and just because
you don't have a college education you
could be some billionaire one day I mean
nothing is a guarantee in life but when
we're talking about the average case
because I think when when I'm talking to
you know the 18,000 people that are
subscribed to this channel
you're probably average I mean that's
just the truth like that you the viewer
you're probably average and that's okay
but we have to give advice I think it's
important to give advice to the average
case and if you're not going to qualify
that like qualify let's say hey if your
super driven kid if you've you know ran
several clubs and been the president of
all of them and all this stuff
none of this apply like this is applies
to you to everyone else don't listen to
this because you're right some sometimes
you know the rule is not you don't
you're not considering the exception of
course they're exception and I want to
make three points first of all
congratulations on the subscribers and
as a guru I'm in full support of your
both channels I didn't know you have the
first channel when we talk but I've
watched many videos did your stuffs
great so congratulations there
thanks I think I'm actually gonna call
you a little bit here Steven yeah dude
so number one is and let me get through
both points okay number one is you just
you just talked about how college has a
bunch of intangibles that you can't
value that have tremendous value that
you said personally have helped you like
yeah three minutes before this if you go
back I don't know as I hung in that
suppose mic elements before you said
quote courses had they selling tangible
skills that you know can you really
quantify those okay so you just made the
same argument for college he made for
course the number one or at least your
little bias for the college but I
understand okay yeah and here's a real
big let me write that down I'm gonna
address that food write it down number
two is here but don't don't don't roast
me to hardly come back number two five
okay when we talked it and I want I
would like to hear this from you and
since those it wasn't being recorded
what the biggest the thing you told me
Annie Thomas is a correct round the
biggest problem you have with a lot of
these gurus is that they're targeting
super young people 18 even younger
sixteen to twenty five-year-olds that
don't have a lot of money that are
trying to better themselves that get
easily gullible pulled in us gaps
correct that that's one of your biggest
problems yes
okay who does college target
it targets 18 people right out of high
school right on high school and they
make huge decisions that impact their
life in many ways and great in many in
many cases in great ways in many cases
in poor ways so first of all I'm not
trying to compare college of course cuz
they're not the same they're both
education but they're completely
different but to be fair to you and to
you know since we're talking about it I
think that's a fair comparison to make
because if that's when your biggest
problems I think you should have a
considerable issue with college because
it doesn't the truth is it doesn't work
for everybody right I mean you can't say
it works for everybody it doesn't maybe
on average it does but isn't work for
everybody there's tons of cases where
people that doesn't work out for them so
how is that okay you know what I mean
that's that's that's my point
all right let me address these in
reverse order okay first of all college
is predatory I should have a problem
with college okay look there are I think
there does need to be more education in
the types of degrees that will set you
up for success and those that won't I
straight up getting a Social Sciences
degree unless you're gonna go do a
masters or a PhD if you don't have a
plan for that degree it's probably not a
good idea it's probably not a good place
you're gonna be the millionth kid
graduating with an International Studies
degree and it's like it may work for you
but the chances are much lower you can
help yourself by making better decisions
I think there needs to be more education
around that and and I'm also not saying
college is perfect I I do think it
worked out for me but I'm not saying
college is perfect but I would heavily
push back against colleges predatory
because again what does College promise
it actually doesn't even promise money
it promises in education it promise it
actually tells you look what we're
actually gonna get you trained up in is
we're gonna make you read a bunch of
books you're gonna do a bunch of
homework you're gonna do all these
things but it never says hey look the
sales pitch for any college is not hey
come to make a million bucks you know
you're gonna be rich they don't and they
don't even promise you're gonna be rich
they say hey you might be minute we're
gonna make you on average middle class
you know what I mean like that's the
real sales pitch of colleges it's like
and that's actually what gurus Mach is
they go what are you gonna go to college
and get a regular job and you know work
nine to five and then retire and it's
like yeah that's that's what most people
should do so I know I mean I don't think
they're predatory do I think they're
perfect no but I would push back that
they're predatory meanwhile the good the
gurus with the Lambo in the garage it's
like they're targeting someone
personally kids want I mean they're like
they're getting in the psychology
they're using psychology to get you so
that's that's number one then soft
skills versus intangibles on this note I
would say kind of the some of the
intangibles I'm talking about are a bit
different from what I would call soft
skills but so I don't know if they're
quite the same I don't know if critical
thinking is the same as like being like
a sales guy because I think you're
trying to like teach like salesmanship
whereas critical thinking as a more
broad thing but I hear what you're
saying I think though if it is the case
that horses are producing intangibles
that are super valuable for the people
that they serve I think that should be
reflected in the average result of that
person even if they don't go on to do
the sales or whatever if you have a
global skill of just being more
persuasive you should be able to see
that in the results they achieve in life
and that's what I'm saying I know we
don't have these guru average guru
average statistics but what I'm saying
is if gurus want to say I have a proven
track record if they want to make the
case that this course is justified how
is it justified how is it justified that
a six-week course can cost two thousand
dollars and there's not mentoring
one-on-one mentoring
how can it be justified that most of the
products the most of the product cost is
just spent on recruiting more people
it's like is college super expensive yes
but what is the money spent on it's
spent on expensive buildings that you
get to sit in it's spent on staff that
sit with you and actually teach you
one-on-one core like not one-on-one on
courses and they all have office hours
or you know one-on-one and meet with
qualified accredited professionals and
so my thing is like okay how are these
courses justifying their own existence
it's like what are you spending money on
why is your course expensive I just need
some kind of a like validation to make
me say okay you're right this guy is not
actually a scam until then I just this
industry dude I'm gonna be honest like
95% of this industry sucks it's again
I'm in it I you're you're talking to the
what's that say you're preaching to the
choir like I know yeah I know I've seen
it
I know that's why I'm here okay I'm here
for a reason well real quick I the last
thing we talked about college I know you
want to get back to the guru stuff but I
will say this you know you talk about
the facts of college and all this I mean
dude if you look at it the cost of
college has gone up exponentially in the
last 30 years right yeah and the median
household income has virtually not moved
I mean it's maybe move with inflation a
little bit if that actually I think it's
lost to inflation so clearly something's
not working okay now this is not a
political debate so I think well you
should just end it there and move back
to the main subject if you're okay with
that
but sure yeah yeah and I agree no there
you go I'm glad we've come to an
agreement my friend yeah college cost is
out it's out of control when I said
there being predatory that's what I mean
I mean I don't there you're right there
mark is not predatory they do have brand
I do have social pressure you need to do
that which it's not really kind of their
fault but not really okay but really the
big picture is what's their pricing
right I mean yeah the price the pricing
is a little sketchy to get out it is
just factually out of control and I and
I agree there is a certain cost of like
even if your product works for a lot of
people if the people it doesn't work for
end up $40,000 in debt how does that
really I hear you I am NOT like I'm a
huge fan of college but I have huge
problems with the end with the you know
kind of these more intractable problems
associated with it and like you said I
mean a lot of its political like you
anyway and that's why I don't want to go
to Bay anyway and I appreciate you being
honest because I can tell your college
gun and I think you being honest here is
the same thing I want to do here with
the gurus I want to be honest and tell
you guys the inside of it another thing
I know you wanted to talk about was the
the refund policies the 30-day action
guarantees that's someone that you'd
like to talk about
yeah yeah yeah I mean I don't know like
I kind of I kind of have a problem but
it to me it is the it is like one of the
smaller guru sins that that they're
making I don't I don't really care that
much what did I took one thing I want to
talk about is you told me that there's
like this book that has all the guru
secrets it's a fantastic book it's
called expert secrets by russell brunson
it is the playbook of the guru business
model now listen there's the gurus that
run their business differently but
they're yours are not that successful
okay this is the playbook so it goes
over you know we talked about how to
start a mass movement I can share that
with you guys if you want there's you
know they'll be right no run run through
it man run through it for the people
watching a copy of it in my business
park I grab that real quick sure your
guru list right here calm secrets
there's another great one out there but
anyway this is a great expert secrets
and half of this book is just talking
about webinars and how to properly do a
webinar I will say this I am a very
biased I'm a massive fan of Russell
Brunson I think he's a he's a very very
smart guy
and yeah I mean if your shouldn't
business all I recommend this but but
anyways the first thing they really talk
about or one of the first things I talk
about this book is creating a mass
movement and this applies to gurus but
it really applies to any mass move than
ever
okay we talked about it on the phone
about presidential elections and there's
three things that you really need the
first is you need a charismatic leader
okay that's why courses are sold through
singular people okay college has been
around for so long there's such a brand
of it that they don't need to do that
but you know like you're not gonna buy a
consulting course if you're like I don't
that's kind of sketchy but if it's like
oh it's Sam ovens you feel like you know
Sam ovens that's different right so
that's number one charismatic leader and
I'm not gonna go into to death but just
know that that's a very important point
and you look at big companies I've done
the same things you think about Apple
will when Apple started you know who's
the face of Apple forever Steve Jobs
mugs now he was the guy in our exec or
Berg I'm Sonya Burke
Elon Musk and and so there's whenever
you're launching a company there's
always going to be a charismatic leader
if you wanted to be successful most of
the time now of course it's always the
case but most
that's what I'm sure you can find a
million case where that's not true but
I'm just telling you okay number two is
okay you need a what's called a future
based cause okay and this is where we
talked about specific about the
presidential elections and I'm not here
to get political am I here to go any
political but just to bring up example
tell them the facts Spencer given the
facts you know you go back to 2016 to
the election and why did Trump win
versus Hillary when without getting
political well one of the reasons is
that Trump had a future based off what
was Trump's campaign slogan everybody
else make America reading it what was
Hillary's I don't remember but he was
I'm with her something like I think it
is I'm with her let's look it up just so
I can be transparent Hillary's campaign
slogan 2016 I'm pretty sure was I'm with
her let's see here
it just says slogan and it says blank
that's that's [ __ ] helpful thank you
let's see here let's just call it I'm
with hearted I I'm pretty sure it was
fine so it wasn't memorable as what it
was was that memorable and it was not a
future based cause because if I'm like
I'm with her I'm like okay well what
does that really mean for the country
why is that really gonna help us like
there's just so many unanswered
questions and he go back to Obama in
2008 okay well Obama's campaign slogan
in 2008 I believe was change okay it was
like one word like change which even
though it's so simple it's a future
based cause yeah it's implying the like
we're going to move forward and change
along the way into some better correct
ID whatever you can go back even to like
mo okay okay MLK's future based cause
was hey we want equality
okay I have a dream right that was the
future based class okay now I tell you
this because every major mass movement
has to have a future based class
I mean religions have it okay I mean you
know I don't know if you lumen I exist
I'm not confirming or denying that but
if it did exist I'm assuming they have a
future based class look everybody number
one okay number two and the last thing
you need is what's called a new
opportunity okay so where does this fit
into the gurus face guys very severe
charismatic leader is the person you
know the the face of it right and you've
got future based cause which is okay
what's our goal here you know for us we
teach something called surplus fund
recovery which without getting into too
much detail it's hey how can we help
people recover the money they're owed
foreclosures that's our future based
clause okay for Sam it's you know how
can we go out and start a successful
business okay how can I go out and make
money for myself right and and that's
kind of the the general one for all
gurus but you know it's all things aside
does basically okay yeah and then the
third thing is is okay what is what is
the new opportunity okay well again for
us the surplus funds that's something
new right for Sam it's consulting okay
and and that's so idea now the reason
why you have a new opportunity versus
something that's better because let's
say I was like hey you know what I'm
gonna educate you slightly better than
College okay that's not a great sales
pitch right that's not it's a terrible
sales pitch hundred it's what's called
an improvement offer okay an improvement
offers when you're doing something
better okay
you don't wanna do something Betty want
to be something different okay what was
Apple slogan think different okay
different so this is what all comes from
this is I highly recommend this book you
should add it to your guru list
this book is referenced a lot and it's
the group that's really interesting I
didn't know about that last one the the
new opportunity that's that's so true
all the gurus and all the webinars
they're going I have a new thing my new
plan my new you know proven whatever my
like with Jason bond picks it's a new
strategy strategy with other guys it's
how I pick successful my formula for
picking successful Shopify store like
products right yeah oh that's all that's
hilarious yeah that's a great point
right now you want to know something and
I cannot believe all my shares with you
guys but you wanna know something crazy
yeah dude let's yeah so okay and this
goes into into sales and I know you've
won at this point you've watched a few
webinars right Oh too many if you don't
mind if you don't mind me asking which
ones had you watched I've watched Dan
Locke I watched ovens I think I like
watch part of crostinis I watched the
guy from shark tank he and Neil Patel's
like they did some kind of a webinar
I've just watched a bass drum well did
you have any specific one in mind
no no I just want to bring up webinars
as a whole because
yeah you'll see a lot with webinars and
I don't know if you've seen this cuz I
know most of us I haven't seen I've seen
Sam's I've seen a little bit of Dan
locks but honestly not that much I've
seen Becker's - I've seen Becker's seem
back so those two webinars in specific
if I can speak about those ones Becker
and Sam's if you think back to them did
they tell you a story was there ever a
time when they told you a story yeah I
think so I think so I can't remember
didn't they say like back when I was
when I was young or whatever I was young
and broke and da da da da da would you
like to know why they did that I'd love
to know
yeah dude give me the story so here's
the demo draw the stuff because this is
not complicated but it's hard to explain
so let me clear this okay so you can you
can you can see this again yeah yeah
yeah okay so here's the deal if I want
you to think or to agree with me on
something I could sit here I could try
too hard you with you about it I could
be like hey Steven courses are the
greatest thing ever
you should start liking course you like
no I don't what now why would I do that
like you're like this is stupid so I
want you to get over here okay and
you're over here and you're just like no
this is not gonna happen like I'm not
I'm not going over there right so in
order for me to do that I have to get
you to come up with the idea okay what I
mean by this I have to get you without
me telling you I have to get you to
think what courses are great okay so how
do you do that the point I make is how
you do that an Apple does this all the
time by the way yeah yep I'll explain
how in a second but just take my word
for now no I'll get there is they they
tell a story okay so if I tell you this
story and I'm like hey did I was right
here and I went through this process and
it sucked and I really wanted to get
here okay and here by the way is not I
wanted to buy a course that's not where
I want to get to well I wanted to get to
was I wanted to get X result and I was
trying to go there and I just kept
hitting brick walls and brick walls and
brick walls right and eventually I
discovered this and this one thing took
me from here to here okay and that's a
really poor story but that's that's the
model okay because if I tell you that
story and I never mention hey there's a
course then in your head you're you're
going along and what do people do when
they hear a story well naturally they
put themselves in the main characters
position they say well if that was me
and I wanted to get there you know I
kind of do want to get there you know
what would like what would that be like
oh my
like I can't imagine you know struggling
and going all through this and then
finally I hit this brick wall my god
this is horrible and then oh my god I
discovered this thing and and it took me
here like that's that's the model that's
why we tell stories okay and that is all
laid out in this book as well it's
called a nappy calls an epiphany bridge
story but you want the person that's
listening or you know comprehend the
story like have that aha moment have the
Epiphany of like oh my god like that
makes sense yeah I mean like that and
and if they start thinking that way then
they're gonna start to agree with you on
things I just heard to agree with you on
things and they're gonna potentially buy
something from you or they're going to
want to be your customer now how does
Apple use this well I mean I watched
your video on Apple's operatin so you
brought it up yourself what is one of
the three so that's one of the four
stages that Apple I believe they do
narratives they do stories right so you
tell the story of how no I'm gonna I'm
gonna go to my daughter I think the
exact ways I'm gonna go to my daughter's
recital I'm gonna take a video of it now
that story is like in your mind you're
putting yourself there like well what if
that was my daughter right and what does
that was her recital and oh my god this
is amazing and I need the I thought okay
that's that's what I'll share it again I
don't want to go too in depth because I
don't think we have the time to go over
it but the information is in I keep I
think I'm gonna be like his best
salesman I should ask for like a
commission or whatever Commission what
the hell Russell no no I actually think
that's really interesting and the other
thing the story does is it makes you
realize okay your process sucked and you
had to screw around for two years to
find this one secret but now you know
the secret well what's the secret what's
the secret Spencer what is the secret
and then I think oh I need to get the
secret from Spencer and then when you
say I've got the secret it's just right
inside these doors just pay a little
just give me your credit card get
through the doors and all of a sudden
that's a much easier sell no absolutely
stories are incredibly powerful that's
super interesting by the way now and
that's where like if you haven't you've
seen like four or five so I I don't
wanna call myself a webinar master but
I've probably watched thousands of hours
of webinars at this point just because
of me trying to work on our business all
and I want to assure you got to get the
webinar perfect I gotta hit the webinar
game right and I know you're a big fan
of the webinar sometimes
you know I've seen amazing webinars you
know I've seen webinars that suck and
I've seen everything in between and the
webinars that are really really really
good and by really good I mean two
things they keep you interested in
listening even if someone has seen one
hundred webinars or probably more right
and yeah and they they convert well
right those are the two things I'm
looking for and I don't know everyone's
numbers but I can tell you right now for
a fact the people that just go on and
talk about oh yeah well you know this is
what we do and this is how we do it and
they're like really monotone I just give
you step-by-step how to do it number one
is what do people say after you give
them they say oh my god I'm overwhelmed
you've given me too much information why
would I buy anything from you because I
already they think they know it all
maybe they do and some of them maybe
they don't but there's too much and then
number two is there anything gonna wash
that far because they're like oh my god
this is too much
right so in many cases okay so that's
where stories come in too and really the
whole point of a good story on a webinar
is you know Brit and I know you're gonna
love this one to break someone's false
belief okay so someone's believing they
need to go down one road how can you
change their mind about that and you
can't just say hey you shouldn't do that
because that doesn't work you know so
the questions how do you do that and
that's that's what the story so I'm glad
we talked about this this is great it
work we're peeling back the layers of
what it means to be a modern guru on the
internet selling webinars whatever all
the trappings that come with it I yeah I
really appreciate this conversation
we're probably running into the edge of
people's attention span actually we
face-planted into it probably thirty
minutes ago but but I really appreciate
you coming on I could see us having
another conversation in the future
because I feel like we have not tapped
out of stuff to talk about but for now
that's probably probably where we're
gonna have to end it to everybody
watching thank you for listening guys we
don't just have testimonials from the
good side the back we have everybody on
we give everyone a chance to talk so Dan
Locke if you're listening I want to talk
to you Dan Dan right now listen to me
listen look me in the eyes
you can come on hafiz' and give your
case please I welcome you to my show
don't ban your students for commenting
come on the show baby
come on the show okay that's all for now
thank y'all later
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
or the car
[Music]